king of speed chess was dethroned by
Magnus Carlson in the speed Chess
Championship finale we may have just
witnessed the match of the Year despite
losing three games in a row for the
first time ever in SCC history Magnus
still outplayed Hikaru Nakamura was not
one-sided when these two go head to head
expect a war in this game Hikaru
discovered a brilliant strategy to shift
the momentum of the entire match oh my
goodness that is beautiful after that it
seemed destined for a Hikaru Victory
determined and unwilling to give up
Magnus willed his way into making a
comeback it all came down to the final
moment Hikaru was about to tie the match
but then he only needs a draw as the
match clock expires and Hikaru is
exasperated Hikaru had its most mate and
it's a draw by agreement and that's how